Speaker 1: Let's talk today about why rightwingers
and Republicans seem to hate.
They really seem furious with electric vehicles.
And we've talked about this anecdotally over
the last few weeks.
There have been these clips of Marjorie Taylor
GREENE making completely incorrect claims
about people are being enslaved by being forced
to get electric vehicles.
Just completely wacky stuff.
But let's actually think it through a little
bit because when you take it at the top level,
you would think that right wingers would love
electric vehicles.
Think about it.
They hate and complain all the time about
high gas prices.
Electric vehicles don't use gas, so that would
be something that should appeal to right wingers.
Right wingers often have this kind of stereotypical
alpha beta male mentality.
They see fast cars as indicative of alpha
male status.
Well, electric vehicles are really fast, so
you'd think that would be something that would
appeal to them.
They claim to like self-sufficiency and not
depending on others.
You can quite literally charge your electric
vehicle at home with solar power harvested
from the solar panels that you own, you don't
need anybody else to help you.
You'd think that that would appeal to them.
You don't need a gas station.
You don't need a fuel tanker to deliver the
gas to the gas station.
Russia can't mess with gas and affect the
gas you get at the gas station.
Think they would love it?
And sort of along that same line.
I mean, you could end the dependance on foreign
oil as well, which is something right wingers
claim to love, but they don't love electric
vehicles.
In fact, they seem to hate them.
And it's another one of these examples where
you have their stated principles and then
you have what's politically convenient or
inconvenient.
And the reality is, right wingers tend to
love oil and gas.
Fossil fuels, they see burning fossil fuels
as a good thing in many cases, and they like
angering people on the left.
And so there is a part of this that is that
right wingers want to protect the established
industry of oil and gas, both for its own
sake and to anger liberals.
And they see electric vehicles as a threat
to fossil fuels.
And that's true.
Electric vehicles are a threat to fossil fuels,
and that's a good thing.
You also have, you know, the Toyota Prius
specifically has become a sort of emblem,
a prototype, a microcosm of what the right
doesn't like.
Right wingers often see the Prius as a very
beta energy vehicle.
They see it as a form of left wing virtue
signaling.
Now, the reality is we are very much beyond
that.
You can get I mean, put Tesla aside.
You can get a Porsche Electric vehicle, Volkswagen,
Audi, Hyundai, what's more Alpha than a Ford
F-150 electric, which is sold out until who
knows when, but the stereotype remains and
it conflicts with what right wingers like.
You've then got the range issue or the supposed
issue, the right wingers sort of idealizing
the great American road trip.
They say, Well, on my electric vehicle I can
only go 250 miles on a charge or 275 or 300
or 330 or 370 or soon to be over 400.
But who actually drives that long without
stopping?
I mean, seriously, like if you just on a normal
road trip, even if you can fill your tank
with 500 miles worth of gasoline, who's really
driving a full four or 500 miles?
When's the last time you drove 300 miles without
stopping?
It's not really an impediment to the great
American road trip.
The right thinks things that the left likes
must be bad things.
And since the left, generally speaking, likes
electric vehicles, the right ends up having
to say that they are bad.
And it is a very strange thing because when
you actually go point by point, they should
be loving these electric vehicles.
Oh, and by the way, I shouldn't forget.
The electric vehicles don't make the big boy
vroom, vroom engine noise.
And I think that that's something that right
wingers also don't like.
So by all accounts, this is something that
they should embrace if they were paying attention
to their principles.
The principles go in the toilet as soon as
they conflict with what's politically convenient.
And that's exactly what we're seeing right
now